for a long time
i
thought that
a military operation
was not
feasible
it was not plausible you know i had my
own cost-benefit analysis
and
even if you put aside all other
considerations
i thought that
to go into ukraine is not in russia's
interests
keep in mind
the collateral damage
which is likely to happen after such an
operation but apparently you know
my course benefit analysis
did not coincide
with that in the kremlin
so i had to wake up to a new reality and
i have
now not just
you know me but all of us will have to
live in this new reality that's your dry
foreign policy analyst analysis how do
you feel about this today what are your
emotions today well you know i
i'm
trying to keep
going i'm trying to
continue doing what i'm doing but of
course i'm depressed you know all of us
are
depressed
and i think that
it's it's very
embarrassing for all of us not only
because we turned out to be wrong but
also because
of course you know
russia
and all russians will be in a difficult
position
in uh
in many countries
not even only western countries but all
over the place for a long time
and
there are many questions to which we
don't have answers
and does that make you wonder about the
the state of your president's mind
well you know
he has his own
vision
maybe you know he
believes that
this damage is acceptable
i don't know
i don't know it's
it's hard to
tell and you're someone who's supported
vladimir putin in the past where you've
thought fit and you advised the kremlin
and today you're depressed about the way
things are going yeah of course you know
i'm depressed i think many of us are
depressed i think that there are many
people in the kremlin who should be
depressed
because
the price
will be
substantial